[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique avec aujourd'hui un débat sur
le débat
le grand débat national décidé par
emmanuel macron pour répondre à la crise
des gilet jaune consultation qui doit
débuter le 15 janvier donc dans deux
jours comment pourquoi faire avec
quelles conséquences nous allons poser
ces questions à nos quatre invités
bonjour à son dîner
bonjour vous êtes créateur d'un groupe
gilet jaune en côte d'or on vous avait
invité en novembre
au tout début du mouvement sébastien
mirek bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
référent de la république en marche au
département de la côte d'or
ludovic rochette bonjour bonjour
président des maires de côte-d'or mer
les républicains de brognon 300
habitants attention 12,312 et jean
vigreux bonjour bonjour vous êtes
historien enseignant à l'université de
bourgogne franche comté spécialiste en
autre du front populaire de mai 68
histoire qu'on verra ne trouvez-vous pas
des correspondances avec ce qui se passe
avant le débat lui-même il y à déjà pour
l'instant la crise marquée encore par
quelques violences hier en tout cas par
une tension extrême dans le pays
vincent di nève fait partie de ceux qui
sont mobilisés au départ mi novembre
contre l'augmentation des prix du
carburant pour le pouvoir d'achat mais
s'en souvient on peut dire que les
tensions sont extrêmes avec l'extérieur
mais aussi au sein du mouvement va rien
cacher on s'en est parlé avant cette
émission vous même vous avez dû subir un
certain nombre de on va dire de violence
comment vous jugez l'évolution de ce
mouvement
et bien tout d'abord effectivement le on
sent une division au sein même des gilet
jaune entre les pacifiques et les entre
guillemets violents et ce qu'ils se
joignent à la partie qui ne sont
aucunement gilet jaune mais qui tire de
ce mouvement là du du profit on va dire
allez casser à les voilà déjà là c'est
le
c'est le souci qu'on rencontre au sein
des gilet jaune
ensuite il ya les soucis également sur
les réseaux sociaux
parce que personne ne veut de
représentants mais tout le monde veut se
faire entendre
on peut pas rentrer tous dans un aller
porter notre message c'est pas possible
on est trop nombreux en france il faut
quand même qu'ils aient un minimum de
structure c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire
la tâche n'est pas simple mais ce n'est
pas facile on va en parler on va voir
comment ça va s'intégrer avec ils ont
tellement ce grand débat vincent direct
vinçon un pays en état de siège tous les
samedis une vie nationale totalement
figée c'est un constat d'échec pour les
marcheurs pour emmanuel macron sébastien
merci non absolument pas non il faut
qu'on repasse de ce stand hystériser
faucon passé un temps de dialogue c'est
extrêmement important il faut vraiment
qu réinstaurer le dialogue et le grand
débat il est là pour ça et on va
s'inscrire dans cette démarche
alors on tant que marcheur en tant que
citoyens surtout pour pouvoir la débat
tous ensemble et trouver des solutions
avant pardon mais avant qu'on parle
vraiment du grand débat quand même vous
vous êtes engagés derrière manuel macron
un an et demi après son élection
est-ce que vous vous attendiez quand tu
gagnes élections présidentielles à ce
qu'on se retrouve à un moment du pays où
il va falloir organiser un débat pour
sortir d'une crise qu'on n'a jamais un
peut-être jamais vu dans ce pays pas
forcément mais en fait si on est
probablement un tournant sociétal pour
construire une société de demain et on a
toujours été dans l'écouté on le sera
encore
on a fait des concertations le programme
présidentiel a été construit par rapport
à la grande marche il ya un diagnostic
une écoute qui a été fait une
co-construction et on va rentrer encore
dans cette phase là avec ce grand débat
donc on affronte ses crises
il faut être responsable et on le
restera et on le sera et on participera
activement par un pont à saint jean
vigreux l'historien voit quoi en 2018 il
y voit une révolte pour du pouvoir
d'achat il y voit une crise de société
une crise d'institutions ont une
insurrection qui cherchent à renverser
le pouvoir
on y voit plusieurs choses d'abord on
essaye de comparer avec le passé il ya
un référentiel du mouvement des gilets
jaunes à la révolution française
assumez-vous
mais c'est peut-être différent il ya un
référentiel parfois à 1968 on a vu des
gilet jaune j'ai fait 68 je fais 2018
sauf qu'il ya des différences il ya de
grandes organisations en 68 comme la cgt
qui le 13 mai lance le mouvement
là on a pas d'organisation ça vient
d'être dit c'est un peu différencié
pluriel polymorphe
il ya différentes choses en revanche ce
qui est ce qui surprend et ce qui est
important c'est que des gens qui ne
prenaient pas la parole prennent la
parole et là il ya un référentiel à 1789
layar référentiel à 36 là il ya un
référent c'est un référentiel à 1968
d'après quels débouchés on donne il faut
une sortie de crise un toute crise doit
avoir un moment donné dans la conflit
qualité il ya le temps du conflit le la
chronologie du conflit le registre
d'actions et en a plusieurs
on aime bien montrer les violences n'y a
pas que des violences le le débat de
fond c'est celui de l'égalité et celui
là il était de 1789 sur l'impôt tout le
monde voulait payer l'impôt parce que
qui paient l'impôt c'était le tiers état
c'était le peuple et pas les privilégiés
et ont créé la citoyenneté française et
ça c'est fondamental sur l'impôt pour
l'intérêt général et donc le mouvement
la réveille nous semble-t-il quelque
chose de profond dans le modèle
républicain
on va et on va voir si ce grand débat
peut être la sortie de la crise que vous
évoquez une sortie il peut y en avoir
d'autres d'autres ludovic rochette c'est
quoi le sentiment des maires des maires
ruraux particulier on sait que beaucoup
de maires ont ouvert des cahiers de
doléances ondimba nous on va on va
reprendre ce rôle peut-être qu'on nous
avait confisqué de deux corps
intermédiaires c'est quoi votre
sentiment c'est que c'est une crise de
quoi du fait qu'on n'a pas écouté les
campagnes que qu'on vous a confisqué
quelque chose c'est plus profond que ça
vous le voyez comment alors c'est vrai
que les maires ont été d'année dernière
un peu des lanceurs d'alerté parce que
on a prévenu lorsque les députés ont été
élus en 2017 on les a réunis on nous a
prévenus on dit attention il va se
passer quelque chose
malheureusement nous a pas écoutés on ne
va pas refaire l'histoire on est dans
une situation qui est aujourd'hui très
compliqué qui nécessite
de la cohésion mais qui nécessite on va
très bien de la proximité dans les
études on voit bien que les maires sont
encore et leurs conseils municipaux sont
encore les seuls élus qui ont de la
considération
alors certes le grand débat c'est l'état
qui va là qui va l'organiser les les
municipalités des maires vont avoir un
rôle à jouer je pense
loin de facilitateur et puis essayer de
permettre une une cohésion dans notre
nation parce que il m'a encore vraiment
cette proximité dans cette dans notre
nation
on a voulu faire toujours trop gros
toujours plus loin aujourd'hui on voit
que la proximité latin indispensable
pour qu'on retrouve un peu tous nos
esprits de votre point de vue ses
récents ses anciens c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné on a l'habitude dans notre
vie politique y compris quand on parle
de décentralisation de dire la droite
dit c'était la faute de la gauche la
gauche dit c'était la faute de la droite
toutes ces parties s'étant succédés au
pouvoir est ce qu'on peut admettre
aujourd'hui qu'il ya une co
responsabilité dans cette crise de
société
il ya eu une accélération c'est très
clair mais effectivement on va pas
refaire l'histoire immédiate des
collectivités locales mais la loi neutre
et a été manifestement un accélérateur
parce qu'on a voulu je le répète vouloir
faire des collectivités de plus en plus
grosse et de plus en plus éloignée des
citoyens
emmanuel macron a donc annoncé ce grand
débat il avait aussi d'ailleurs annoncé
10 milliards toulouse sûrs d'urgence
mais on n'en parle plus tellement en ce
moment c'est la commission nationale du
débat public qui intervient
régulièrement pour des débats importants
qui doit chapeauter ce débat on se
souvient par exemple qu'en bourgogne
avait travaillé sur la rcea dans les
questions qui étaient posées sur la
privatisation de la rcea vincent guinée
est ce que c'est de votre point de vue
la bonne solution pour répondre à ce qui
se passe
le grand débat ouais est-ce que puisque
c'est le thème de notre émission
aujourd'hui et puis c'est vraiment notre
question est ce que c'est ce qu'il faut
faire donner la parole aux gens leur
permettent de s'exprimer
ben
c'est clairement ce qui est demandé par
les gilet jaune c'est d'être entendus et
qu'on voit en face des résultats on a
l'impression alors je vais parler
peut-être plus au monde être entend
s'exprimer être attendu c'est pas
exactement la même chose
oui parce que s'exprimer je pense que
c'est fait depuis le début du mouvement
on voit la colère qui monte dans la rue
on voit les fortes mobilisations de
gilet jaune 1 mettant candé gilet jaune
demandent le départ du président de la
république c'est pas comme ça que ça va
se passer dans la vème république
non non on est la colère des fois fait
très certainement dire des quelques
bêtises on peut pas on peut crier macron
démissions etc
je conçois ont fait pas partir un
président comme ça je rappelle que notre
mouvement est apolitique
c'est important de le rappeler c'est
juste la parole du peuple
en face maintenant compte qu'on s'est
exprimé il faut quand même des choses
concrètes et il faut qu'on que le
président et le gouvernement nous
entende
j'ai l'impression comme la dernière fois
qu'ils 100 passages télé président c'est
de la flûte en quoi ces deux-là plus
concrètement pourquoi ces deux là plus
de canton quand ils proposent je le
disais 10 milliards de mesures d'urgence
l'augmentation du smic des choses comme
ça donc est ce que ce n'est pas assez
pour vous non il faut des choses
concrètes
il faut quand on annonce 100 euros pour
pour le smic etc
j'ai pas les chiffres parce que c'est
pas bon c'est pas mon boulot mais
clairement ça va intéresser
très peu de monde au sein du d'humour
enfin au sein des français même tout ce
qu'il a pu annoncer là alors on voit que
c'est un pas mais c'est un pas
on vous donne de la main droite et on
récupère la main gauche en tout cas dans
votre participation au mouvement vous
allez participer à ce grand débat vous
allez essayer d'organiser des choses
bien sûr vous y serez oui vous serez
dedans et vous avez le sentiment qu'à
une partie de gilet jaune qui
souhaiteront pas être dedans ou pas donc
c'est une vraie demande générale forte
non c'est une demande je pense que
chacun s'intéresse aujourd'hui à comment
faire monter le message est pour moi
c'est une bonne solution
forcément vous avez prononcé le mot de
cahiers de doléances tout à leur joie là
donc ça fait très révolution française a
fait on à l'imaginaire des états
généraux on sait comment on apporte
étudiant mais en même temps aujourd'hui
c'est pas le même contexte c'est pas la
même société il ya d'autres depuis ce
grand mouvement révolutionnaire il ya eu
une installation de la république avec
des corps intermédiaires et ses corps
intermédiaires où sont ils c'est là la
grande question est comment on s'adresse
à eux comment on ne les méprise pas
comment on ne les contourne pas il ya le
rôle des syndicats il ya le rôle des
associations
ce qui est intéressant c'est ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure c'est que
maintenant les gilet jaune s'organisent
en associations l'association de loi
1901 n'oublions jamais que si une des
grandes conquêtes de la république qui a
été fait contre l'église je vous coupe
parce que j'ai envie de vous poser cette
question est ce que les corps
intermédiaires ont pas été aussi
contourner parce qu'ils ne
représentaient plus les gens qui
aujourd'hui sont sur les ronds-points
terre qu'est ce qu'un moment donné il
n'y a pas aussi cette cause là en
réalité les deux il ya les deux causes
je vais pas terminé à la démonstration
il ya les enjeux effectivement que ces
corps intermédiaires peut-être pour
certains ne représente plus la société
mais c'est un temps long si une colère
sourde longue et je pense qu'elle
remonte à beaucoup plus longtemps que
l'immédiateté là bien sûr il ya les
enjeux d'un abandon fondamentale d'un
des grands symboles de liesse f
au moment où on dit à différentes
personnes fait plus d'efforts soyez plus
participatif à l'effort national et
cetera on retape va dire les petits et
on apprend que le grand patron de
renault touche 45000 euros par jour paye
ses impôts aux pays bas et c'est donc là
il ya un enjeu d'injustices sociales et
fiscales flagrant et ça ça participe de
notre modèle républicain
en revanche vous avez raison de dire
est-ce qu'on a une dégénérescence des
organisations à faut se poser la
question mais est-ce que
en train de remplacer quelque chose par
ailleurs l'intérêt général c'est la
somme des individualités et là on est
sur un autre débat qui n'est pas
simplement philosophie qui n'est pas
simplement sociale mais qui aussi
d'organisation de la vie publique
on a évoqué tout à l'heure la logique de
verticalité du pouvoir il faut aussi
deloriste l'horizontalité du pouvoir on
n'est pas que dans une logique verticale
mais ça c'est lié aux institutions de la
vème république
sébastien y on a reproché m nl macron
d'avoir on va dire contourner les corps
intermédiaires
c'est une façon ça ce grand débat ça
peut être une façon de recréer ce qui ce
qui a été contournée alors on se posait
la question quand on est volontairement
contourner parce que ça n'était plus
représentatif
c'est en tout cas quelque chose
d'important de votre point de vue ce
débat il revient juste sur un point
effectivement il ya eu dans les mesures
d'urgence au niveau économique et
sociales qui ont été annoncées au mois
de décembre 10 milliards d'euros qui ont
été annoncées et sur des mesures
extrêmes importants notamment avec plus
de justice sociale et qui était une des
revendications des gilet jaune notamment
avec la taxation des grandes entreprises
qui font des bénéfices en france qui
vont payer des impôts comme les gaffes à
comme ces choses là donc il ya eu des
revendications qui ont été faites pour
ce qui est du grand des bains et de
l'implication des corps intermédiaires
ils vont être impliqués parce que dans
le grand débat national
il est annoncé et l'ensemble des corps
intermédiaires pourront participer à
savoir les associations les syndicats
des citoyens qui se manifesteront auprès
de la commission nationale du débat
public
donc chacun doit s'emparer de ce grand
débat c'est des revendications on a vu
avec les parlementaires dès vendredi
dernier une centaine de gilet jaune à
leur demande
on a commencé le dialogue le grand débat
n'ait pas commencé
attendons d'avoir la lettre du président
de la république qui va arriver demain
la lettre français pour qui va cadrer ce
grand débat qui va nous donner et qu'on
ait confiance et puis qu'on se mobilise
par rapport à ça je pense que c'est
extrêmement important
on doit restaurer le dialogue ça me
paraît extrêmement important avec
l'ensemble des corps et notamment les
crises internes et dans les corps
intermédiaires il est maire s'il vient
de se rendre compte des crochets vous
allez vous par exemple brognon si on
vous le demande vous allez organiser on
sait que les mères peuvent le faire mais
ils sont pas obligés de le faire
françois rebsamen a dit d'ailleurs ce
matin sur europe 1
à dijon ils le frappent haïti opposera
pas mais il le fera pas la mf
l'association des maires de france a
pris une position en général ou où
chacun fera comme mesure position c'est
que on fait confiance à chacun des
maires pour essayer d'aider comme il le
peut ce débat alors soit sur
l'organisant soit 100 mettant à
disposition des salles mais ce qui est
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
l'état se rend compte enfin qu'il y a
des représentants de l'état mais aussi
élus qui sont de proximité qui ont été
comme beaucoup de territoires d'ailleurs
mépriser à l'automne dernier les maires
sont là encore pour aider l'état c'est
le trop le site un mot juste sais pas si
vous le savez c'est aussi un miracle les
cahiers de doléances qui ont été ouverts
dans les mairies qui avait pas une forme
on va dire légal enfin en pratique ça va
être intégrée au grand débat on va en
faire quelque chose on le sait ou sur
les quais de les ans il ya certains ça a
été remonté par l'association des maires
ruraux de france il ya eu çà participera
à la contribution
donc oui après sur le cadrage notamment
nous en tant que marcheur de la
république en marche on participera au
débat aussi alors le débat est un
partisan organisé par le grand la
commission nationale du débat public
mais en tant que représentant de la
république en marche on organisera des
ateliers d'idées avec des citoyens avec
des gilets jaunes avec des marcheurs
pour avoir une compétition une
contribution qui est là plutôt partisane
sur les grandes les grandes choses il
crochète vouloir y est
on a évité officiellement le président
la république les maires de bourgogne
franche comté a invité le président
espère qu'il viendra parce que il a
décidé de faire le tour des régions en
l'accueillera à condition que ce soit
une caravane publicitaire
gouvernementale mais là encore nous on
est prêts ce dialogue et on a des
solutions à apporter notamment par
exemple dans question la question de la
mobilité qui est de 1 une question
fondamentale pour le pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui nos concitoyens et qui était
au départ du mouvement et en même temps
on sait qu' un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes en ce moment de syndicats
d'associations sur de quoi on va parler
on a eu l'exemple du début de ce débat
qui avait été lancé par le conseil
économique et social
on a vu que c'est l'opposition au
mariage pour tous qui était sorti en
premier dans la volonté de discussion
vous voyez ça comment vincent guinée ce
qui a annoncé que le gouvernement a fixé
quatre grands thèmes pour discuter
est-ce qui a le risque qu'un certain
nombre de gens veuillent aller sur un
certain nombre de sujets bon conte des
gens je pense à la peine de mort on
pense à des sujets des sujets comme
celui là parce qu'on dit beaucoup que
l'extrême droite est présent devant ce
mouvement et elle essaie de d'amener ces
thèmes dans le débat mais que ce soit
l'extrême droite extrême gauche tous les
partis sont présents dans le dans le
débat après sa naissance en marquage
plus fort de d'extrême pas spécialement
pas spécialement tous les partis sont
dans tous les partis essaye de récupérer
le mouvement rappelle que comme le
mouvement c'est la parole du peuple le
peuple étant composé de gens de droite
de gauche d'extrême droite d'extrême
gauche et c'est pour ce débat là il faut
qu'on reste tout de même concentrer sur
certaines questions
la principale étant le pouvoir d'achat
donc qu en règle déjà ce problème là il
ya ensuite on verra pour la peine de
mort et le reste il vous semble
important c'est la serbie règles de
cadrer ce débat où il peut partir alors
il ya eu un cadrage j'ai eu quatre
thèmes qui ont été annoncés et qui
seront probablement révoqué dans la
lettre aux français que emmanuel macron
va mettre à envoyer aux français qui
sont la transition écologique la vie
quotidienne on a parlé de la mobilité de
la démocratie citoyenneté de la réforme
de l'état des services publics
donc il ya des grands thèmes
effectivement qui sont notés mais tous
les sujets sont ouverts tous les sujets
sont ouverts moi je reviendrai pas sur
des progrès sociétaux qui ont été faits
sur des grandes questions
voilà c'est une nature progressiste donc
je reviendrai pas sur ces sur ces choses
là
pour ce qui est des choses on a parlé de
la mobilité notamment la loi sur la
mobilité a été arrêté comme sur la
réforme des constitutions parce qu'on va
attendre ce grand débat national pour
revenir dessus pour attendait les
revendications des citoyens par rapport
à ça la mobilité est capital pour notre
territoire il ya effectivement le besoin
de deux d'écouter les citoyens en plus
proche les mères seules avec ça veut
dire quand le gouvernement s'est trompé
quand il a décidé juste d'augmenter les
taxes sur le gasoil en disant ça va être
une mesure environnementale
c'était donc ya une volonté de réécouter
alors il ya eu des le président l'a même
dit lui-même ya eu des erreurs qui ont
été faites dans la communication dans
certaines choses mais il faut écouter
les français il faut dialoguer sur ces
points là et la transition écologique
elle est extrêmement importante on peut
pas dire actuellement que ce n'est pas
un problème il faut se comparer après
comment faire la méthode mais il faut
revenir dessus et c'est l'objectif de ce
grand débat donc voilà on est prêt à
rediscuter le gouvernement le premier
d'ailleurs en par rapport à ça parce que
effectivement et des revendications qui
revient même s'il ya eu déjà des
avancées qui ont été comme été fait
c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est comment
on répond aux interrogations et aux
quotidiens des français les réformes le
quotidien des réformes qui est qu'ils
sont enchaînés n'est pas le quotidien
des français donc c'est à nous aussi de
leur chien
les quatre thèmes que vous évoquez c'est
une sacrée autocritique
parce que si on prend le quatrième thème
des services
plus proche plus efficace c'est
complètement
al'inverse de la politique qui a été
menée depuis des années de vouloir
supprimer les services justement de
proximité donc là encore on va pas
refaire ce match mais les quatre thèmes
pose vraiment à ce que est ce que ce que
les gilet jaune vous dise s'est pas
arrêté de faire le match justement je
pense je pense aussi
ça veut bien prouver quand même que les
associations d'élus étaient pas dans le
four et que si elles ont alerté c'est
peut-être que parce qu'on en proximité
on sent ce qui se passe vous voulez
réagir sur un point c'est à dire la
logique aussi dans quoi et à quand
s'installe ce dialogue
c'est important de trouver une sortie de
crise mais il faut pas non plus que ce
soit simplement quelque chose qui soit
factice mais qu'on entende ce qui a été
dit qu'on entende une parole et qu on ne
méprise pas à cette parole parce que
depuis trop longtemps
il ya un mépris alors on peut reprendre
casse-toi pauv' con on peut reprendre
les sens dans on peut reprendre lé
dernier de cordée on peut reprendre les
gens qui ne sont rien les ouvrières il
est trés ça fait quand même c'est grave
ce discours est donc il ya un moment
c'est le respect est donc ce respect il
doit passer par une écoute un dialogue
et un dialogue qui doit déboucher bien
sûr sur quelque chose parce que ça
ramène à d'autres types de violence
parce que jusqu'à l'heure on présente la
violence des casseurs mais il ya une
violence sociale il faut pas le nier
il ya une violence légitime qui est
celle de l'état et il a ces derniers
temps je trouve qu'elle quand même aussi
pas mal de deux syndicalistes ou même le
gilet jaune cotait condamnés à des
peines très dur car peut-être qu'il y
ait une loi d'aministie affaire puisque
dans toute crise de notre pays on a
pensé à la mystique à la sortie à la la
soirée alors moi au delà de la sortie
j'ai envie de prolonger avec vous jean
vigreux puis les autres s'exprimant
aussi sûr si on tient compte de ce qui
ressort de ce débat et que donc la
politique publique est orientée par ce
débat est-ce que c'est pas tout
simplement la fin de la cinquième
république et la femme notre système
politique et que ça y est c'est mûr et
il faut passer à autre chose
d'abord la vème république ça fait un
moment qu'elle est en crise qu'on le
veuille ou non
même si elle dure depuis longtemps il ya
eu plusieurs propositions ces dernières
années sur une sixième république shirov
on va dire pour baliser
pour tout le monde que dans votre
parcours politique vous avez aussi été
proche d'arnaud montebourg jean louis
j'assume totalement
cet engagement il ya très longtemps qui
n'est plus maintenant qu'à plein de
raisons et ses terrains mais je l'assumé
en revanche il faut aussi dépasser le
modèle républicain c'est quoi le grand
modèle républicain en france depuis la
révolution l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
avec les maires le un plus un égale 1
ça c'est fondamental c'est quelque chose
qui n'existe pas ailleurs une commune
plus une commune un canton un canton
plus un canton un département un
département plus un département un état
nation et on était à la fois dans une
logique verticale et horizontale un
moment donné elle s'est perdue sous la
vème république il ya eu les lois de
décentralisation très importantes qui
ont été faites au début des années 80 il
faut un autre acte ii de la
décentralisation pour que les citoyens
soient effectivement entendu mais la
grande question c'est pas simplement
être seul en europe c'est de le penser
aussi à l'échelle européenne c'est à
dire que si vous mener une politique qui
dépend simplement de quelque chose qui
vient alors on va dire d'ailleurs
il ya une contrainte budgétaire
importante qui aujourd'hui dépôt ce qui
dépend excusez-moi des logiques tout
simplement de maastricht et et de la
suite de maastricht alors qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
est-ce que c'est pas un problème qu'il
faut prendre à bras le corps pour éviter
la montée des nationalismes comme on a
partout en europe et pas simplement en
europe au brésil aux états unis donc la
logique et l'es2 d'écouter la
souveraineté populaire et ça c'est vrai
que ce débat mené au coeur la question
de la souveraineté populaire qu'est ce
que la souveraineté et ça c'est
fondamental
vincent guinée jusqu où comment ce
serait réussi un débat pour vous c'est à
dire il faut il faut que les choses
changent réellement dans le pays il faut
que vous attendez quelque chose de
concret qui doit sortir de ce débat
comment on comment vous le jugerez vous
la réussite ou pas et l'efficacité de la
question n'est pas simple
on va le juger tout simplement quand la
fin du mois ne commencera pas le le 15
justement ça va être ça va être rapide
si les mesures qui sont prises sont est
annoncée sont concrètes
en effet le mouvement on peut bien
s'imaginer qui va qui va s'atténuer ce
est ce que vous voulez d'ailleurs qui
continue pendant le grand débat ce
mouvement
dès samedi parce que c'est devenu un
rite en france bien sûr mais j'ai une
question s'est enfin on attend enfin
qu'attend le gouvernement pour stopper
les actes là on en est à l'acte 9 je
crois 10 11 12 un an donné il va falloir
que ces défilés c'est vous qui décidez
défilé c'est qu'ils organisaient le
mouvement des gilet jaune je regrette
mais c'est quand même le président
pardon ou c'est lui qui organise ce
mouvement c'est lui qui a mis le peuple
en colère
et c'est à lui de prendre les mesures
pour calmer tout c'est toutes ces
tensions
donc en écoutant son peuple et en
surtout en tenant compte de ce qu'il dit
quoi de pas prendre ça à la légère ces
destins dirait que ça va évaluer comment
c'est à dire combien de mesure combien
parce qu'il va y avoir énormément de
choses dans ce débat ça va être énorme
ça va être gigantesques on va on adule
mais en fait on a du mal à l'imaginer ce
qui peut ressortir de ça on va donner on
va laisser on va voir comment ça va se
passer est en fait en pratique
chacun va pouvoir remonter ces
informations ces doléances donc c'est
important de le faire c'est important
d'y participer après il y aura tout sera
entendue tout sera écoutée et puis il y
aura un diagnostic issa faye qui sera
fait comme on l'a fait auparavant avec
le programme présidentiel
on a toujours fait ce qui devra se
valide et politiquement ce diagnostic
est à dire qu on parle beaucoup et
éventuellement d'une dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale de quelque chose
comme ça parce que il va falloir le
valider ou en tout cas le lieu de
calibrer démocrate âgé des conclusions
du débat du grand débat avant d'avoir
commencé
laissons participons à ce grand débat
national allons donner nos doléances nos
idées échangeons ensemble et trouver des
solutions ensemble
après il y aura des décisions peut-être
politique à faire mais là moi je vais
pas je reste à ma place en tout cas de
citoyens et je participerai comme
d'autres et le maximum de personnes
après sur l'organisation sur le kes
comment ça se fera pour les décisions
faisons confiance aussi il ya de la
transparence de la partialité
faisons confiance aux choses et
participons à ce grand débat national et
de vie crochète oui il faut que la la
république entame encore une panse une
nouvelle phase de décentralisation
s'appuyant sur les élus municipaux parce
que
les élus municipaux les maires se sont
quasiment aussi des bénévoles sont des
gens qui bossent aussi quoi un métier à
côté de leur mandat vous nous fait un
plaidoyer pour les mères oui oui et de
la proximité
et puis deuxièmement ça sera peut-être
tenté d'amuser ça s'apprend et ça prend
un peu de temps mais c'est aussi une
alternative politique démocratique et ça
c'est très difficile à y répondre
le bric le débouché et voilà le débouché
politique de ce qui va se passer
merci à tous les cas je suis obligé de
l'arrêter ce débat c'est terminé mais il
va bien sûr se prolonger dans les
semaines qui viennent
merci d'avoir participé à notre débat
tout de suite vous retrouvez la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique
au revoir et bon dimanche
[Musique]